if we prove to you the prophet muhammad
is a final messenger would you accept it
if you were to prove it then sure so
would you denounce
judaism and become a muslim if it was by
a logical process then of course
isn't it ken could have not the children
of israel come
to god get closer to god through a
gentile prophet that is a true prophet
because they yes why did they not
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
advance
half past i've got to go to synagogue so
we've got 19 minutes
he's recording here okay assalamu
alaikum what happened to a better
hope you guys are wearing each other uh
we've got a jewish brother here uh
what's your name
josh how are you doing josh i'm doing
all right you look tired
oh yeah i've been here for hours that's
good is it i haven't seen you here
before
i've been here i come here a lot yeah
yeah that's good
what's what's your like what we wanted
to know is
your concept of god in judaism
and we wanted to tell you guys about
what's our concept of god in islam and
wanted to talk about maybe the
differences or the common
commonalities i think that judaism and
islam have a very very similar concept
of god
we both believe that there is only one
god
we believe that one god is indivisible
unlike the christians who say that it's
divisible into three
okay we believe that he's not made up of
parts as do you
we believe that god is above our
understanding
um that he is omnipotent omniscient
and omnipresent we believe he created
the whole universe and everything in it
all concepts literally everything
we believe that nothing exists without
god allowing it to be
um we believe that god um
revealed himself to three million people
at mount sinai and gave us
the uh the torah okay and uh
he spoke to various prophets over the
years
and um he gave us a written and an oval
law at sinai
yeah interesting you know when you say
that it reminds me of for example
there's books that we study on the
matters of creed uh there's two books
there's
a team yeah so these are books that
tells us the
doctrine of islam who god is so we have
something called um we worship like for
example we single out god in his
lordship
and we single him out in his worship and
we affirm his names and his attributes
so when you were speaking i was it was
reminding me of the things that we
studied
the things that we went through because
you said a lot of stuff yeah so for
example you do not you reject the
concept of trinity
you do not believe god is like his
creation yeah uh you know
you you you believe in his oneness um so
when you're talking
it reminds me of islam so
we have a agreement that's what allah
says in the quran come to common terms
with the people of the book that we
worship no other than god
so so far we're on the right track it
seems like we are both coming to good
terms
of worshiping god alone you said one
statement i just wanted to clarify you
said that god revealed himself
to three million israelites yeah what do
you mean by revealed himself
so what that means is that god um
made some sort of speech we're not sure
what it means when god speaks but
it means something we just don't know
what it means so did he reveal himself
or did he
speak he spoke we're not sure what spit
what god's speaking actually
sounds like that's interesting because
we believe god speaks
yeah and we believe the quran is his
word uncreate uncreated word yes so what
we believe is that whenever
whenever the torah talks about god in
physical terms like he
speaks or he has a hand or he regrets or
anything like
that it's really an anthropomorphism
because we can't understand
god in any way um and and therefore
the only way we can understand him is
through human terms
okay so when you say for example when
god speaks or for example god we believe
for example
god speaks we've affirmed that he has a
hand
yeah but it's the way it befits his
majesty so for example we have
certain groups in islam who deny this
concept
yeah which we believe that it's a
different topic there's innovation yeah
so for example we say that god has a
hand
the way it befits his majesty but a lot
of them what happens is they use their
mind over the text
so we say look if the quran and the
sunnah if allah affirms
himself himself and his attributes to us
which we affirm
then we accept it we say god has a hand
the way it befits his majesty
we don't but what happens is certain
fractions groups in islam
they say oh if god has a hand he should
have a limb
if he has a limb so you're laughing do
you know why you're laughing because
you don't you know we don't mean that
yeah right exactly so
yes if there was some brothers here
they'll say you're a salafi
you're on the right thing uh ideology
regarding creed yeah
and that's important because we go back
to how the sahaba the salaf understood
it and we say look we go with what
they're saying
so when you smirk i find it very
interesting because he was like come on
you even know
that when god almighty has a speech and
for example his hand
or be his shin it's the way we say
speech it's not the same
exactly so we affirm we affirm that he
does but the way he defeats his majesty
yeah
so it's very similar so because when you
said he revealed himself to three
million israelites i wanted to know what
you mean by reveal did he show himself
of course not
okay exactly so so far it seems like we
have a lot of commonalities
where do we differ why are we why why do
why do we have uh
like two different religions we have two
different religions for
one reason and the reason is because
we believe that at sinai there was given
not only a written law
but an oral law which told you to how to
interpret it
okay and you don't believe that and
because you don't believe that
you don't believe that the prophet
malachi
was the last of the prophets and you
believe that the prophets could continue
after that
whereas we have an oral tradition that
that was passed down
that malachi was the last prophet and
therefore we can't accept any prophets
after him
okay do you so are you really where we
split up
okay so far like also one thing i just
want to clarify as well do you believe
that god rested on the seventh day
in an anthropomorphized way in a way
that fits its majesty as you would say
yes
okay we we believe that for instance we
have some called
yeah it's a very powerful uh verse in
the quran
for example let me get the translation
and we'll read it because it's very
important when it comes to this matter
of um
yeah yes one second let me get you it
because i want to read it for you
and because it's very important
it touches on this topic yeah
okay okay
yeah it's long it's about the cow i
haven't finished it yet really that's
good you're reading it here
yeah yes may god guide you yes
started learning me too i i i'm i'm
totally learning too okay
so let's go to verse 250
[Music]
something that we read it's a powerful
dua it says the following yeah
and tell me if you relate with this as a
jewish person yeah allah
god there is no god but he the living
the
sustaining neither dozing off tiredness
overtakes him
nor sleep to him belongs all that is in
the heavens and the earth
all that is on the earth who can
intercede with him without his
permission
he knows what is before them and what is
behind them while they encompass nothing
of his knowledge except what he wills
his kursi chair extends to the heavens
and the earth
and it does not worry either and it does
not worry him to look after them
so here there's something that says in
the beginning he does not get tired
no sleepover takes him so now even
though you're
saying that he sleeps but not
yet yeah he doesn't sleep it says in
psalms
behold um the the behold the
the guardian of israel does not sleep
and does not slumber
and yet we know that he that and yet we
know in genesis
that he did something on the seventh day
which was called rest
we don't know what that means because of
course it's just anthropomorphism
it's it's it's something it's we're
ascribing physical attributes to god
even though we know that he's not
physical
so okay so what god's rest is it's not
the same as what ours okay so in the
same way that god's speech is not the
same as our speech god's hand is not the
same as our hands
in the way god exists is not the way we
exist
now when you said for example um
god oh when he said he he rested
can we say that god wields
certain things but on the seventh day he
didn't will like meaning
like can you is that what you mean like
he just didn't do
i i'm not because god is above our
understanding i don't know what it
actually means when it says he rested i
don't know i know that it's that i know
that
it says that god ceased from doing on
the seventh day
i know that okay um whatever that means
i know it says god rested on the seventh
day and it says god sanctified the
seventh day
okay but we don't know what these things
mean all we can do is relate to
to the anthropomorphism that is being
said okay okay but no that's not wrong
that gives us a bit of an understanding
okay
so so far we can say that we both
believe in the governance of god we do
not we
deny the whole trinity the whole
worshiping now
as muslims where do we stand in your
religion
what are we i know we're the gentiles
but do we have a belonging in the
hereafter
um and also the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him
what do you guys see him as like like um
if you just tell us so the
um so in our so one of our great rabbis
was called the rambam
known in english as maimonides uh he was
uh he was a rabbi who
was grew up in spain and had to move um
to um yes and had to move to morocco
and then eventually egypt and then
israel and he
said that the that that
those who follow the nazarene i.e the
christians
and those who follow the the madman
which is how he referred to muhammad
because he thought he referred to him as
mad um
i i haven't have i've been sent to this
world
by god to spread the principle of one
god
to the pagans so we believe that you
have a very important purpose in this
world
that you are that i mean you went to
india you went to africa
and you and you turned all these pagans
into people who believe in one gods and
that's an incredible thing
but then how can prophet muhammad be
classified as mad
when he's read a lot of nations of idol
worship
because because we believe that he was a
false prophet
we believe that that that god did not
actually speak to him
we believe that because that because
the quran contradicts the torah that
therefore
the uh the quran must not be true but we
do believe that the message of muhammad
is a true message
okay do you believe that the prophet
muhammad is a prophet for the gentiles
um no you don't believe that some i
heard some
jewish sex believe one rabbi who
wrote it in his book but he lived at a
time
when jews are being forcibly converted
to islam in yemen so i don't think we
can
take what he says at face value if it's
true what you're saying that they were
persecuted because
a lot of jews did live in harmony in
muslim lands where they were suffering
persecution
if that is true now the thing is this if
we prove to you the prophet muhammad is
a final messenger would you accept it
if you were to prove it then sure so
would you denounce
judaism and become a muslim if it was by
a logical process then of course
okay that's so that shows your honesty
and that's that's that's good
what kind of proof would you require in
order to
um like for us to show you that the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
was just a fulfilling the message of
moses
and uh the rest well believe in jesus
you don't um
so what evidence would you require that
would get you thinking what is it you
need to give me a
yeah so the evidence i would need is as
follows
um and it's based on the following i'm
gonna have to introduce it
we as jews as i said believe that our
ancestors
had this mass revelation three million
people at sinai
we heard god speak to us we were given
the torah we were given the oral toe and
the written torah
and the oral torah said that
the last gentile prophet was belong and
after that
prophecy left the gentiles
i don't know how they plant in english i
i've always been taught as bilom
okay um and spelt in english b-a-l-a-a-m
it's brought in mentioned in the book of
numbers okay um so
the he says that after his death
prophecy left the gentiles and
the rabbis said that after malachi
after the prophet malachi malachi
prophecy left the jews
so at that point prophecy has left the
world now unless you can
prove to me that our law is wrong
then i would not believe that islam is
true because islam can only be true
if prophecy had not left and not left
belong
now there is an additional point that i
would not believe
islam unless you also show to me
that the written torah is also not true
why
because the quran and the written torah
disagree on i mean i found the list
about five different points
but those five points are enough to say
that one of them
they contradict each other so unless you
were to tell to prove to me that the
written and oral torahs are both not
true
then i would not believe islam okay so
you did
say that the last gentile prophet was
bilam
so does that you need to accept that god
sent prophets
that were gentiles yes god said promise
that were gentiles okay
so now can god send another prophet
who is a gentile because the children of
israel broke their covenant with him
and therefore god almighty chose from
the line of ibrahim's
two sons ishmael and isaac and
in the line of isaac we affirmed those
prophets
and then what happened is because you
broke the covenant with god
god as a punishment chose the prophet
muhammad who was because
you said that there was gentile prophets
before so what happened is in the
lineage of ishmael
uh which prophet muhammad's lineage goes
to is that he was the final prophet
who came to affirm to the jews and to
the christians and to the whole world
that he is the final messenger because
he comes with the law now you said that
there's five things that disagree with
the torah from the quran
well if we get that list out the thing
is god almighty it's not that god
changes his mind
it's that god when god sends laws and
sanctions he does it to test people
so god might say for example that in the
old testament you're not allowed to eat
come on
you're not allowed to eat come on me
right yeah we're not allowed to hit
camera okay so when i confronted the
black israelites about four or five
years ago
which they believe you guys are fake and
that's vice versa when i confronted them
they said oh no islam is folks because
we are told that we could i need to
leave at half past
okay three minutes left three minutes
left we can continue next week so the
thing is they said no
because in our book says you can't come
on me in your book uh no in the book in
the sunnah
it says that you can yeah so i say these
are little petty issues
but what i would say is that what
okay
yeah so the thing is sorry so the thing
is um
yes so the thing is that if god almighty
sent down prophets that were gentiles if
the children of israel broke the
covenant
god forgot to punish them as a lot like
if you think it logically
sends another prophet is that not
plausible
is it plausible yes but does it befit
his majesty to change
it to to it's not changing to to to say
that prophecy has left uh has left the
gentiles
and then to go back on that i don't
believe that before his majesty
okay no but the thing is if the children
of israel have broke the covenant with
him and have not listened to him
and it said god said sorry to interrupt
god said that that even if we break the
covenant he will not abandon
us if we return to god then he will
it says unto tommy 30 if we return to
god then god will accept us back
you're right i agree with you can you
turn back to god via a new prophet
the from the gentiles who is from the
lineage of ibrahim alaihissalam the
prophet abraham
and can you not turn back to god via him
because the the jews
the jews in um in medina yeah
i thought what's the other name from
madinah
they rejected the prophet because they
were waiting in those lands for the
final prophet to come
and they were waiting the messiah well
they were waiting for the final prophet
or the economist messiah
to come and they knew the prophet like
they knew the back of their hand
the only reason they rejected him is
because he's not a jew
is that a correct method because they
had a right they had an opportunity
to correct their affairs with god by
following a messenger even if he's a
gentile
because to say oh no he has to be an
israelite is asking god
to pick and choose like oh no we isn't
that
i'm sorry simple i'll ask simple because
you need to go synagogue here you go
you've got one minute 15 seconds ago
okay can i ask this question quickly
isn't it ken could have not the children
of israel
come to god get closer to god through a
gentile prophet
that is a true prophet could they yes
why did they not
why did they not because they don't
believe he's a true puppet
because if we prove it he was if they
knew he was okay we'll have to tell you
next week
okay if they knew he was and they
rejected him is that right or wrong if
they knew he was a true prophet
if they had known he was a true prophet
then they would be wrong to
go against him but i don't believe they
knew that he was a true prophet because
i believe it was a false prophet
okay josh thank you very much for your
time i'll be here
thank you very much thank you so guys um
as we is he recording
yeah so that was a really nice
discussion he had to go to the synagogue
which is understandable
um it's very important for us to have a
dialogue in discussion with
christians jews and it's very important
that josh is a nice gentleman
he's polite well spoken etc uh
he believes that the for the prophet saw
sallam is a false prophet
we know he's the true prophet but
obviously him stating that
he's stating that because he's not aware
he's not alhamdulillah
the message hasn't reached him and
that's what we're trying to convey
inshallah and he did say
if he is he would accept him inshallah
that's between him and his lord
but uh yeah so yeah he expressed himself
and we are different but he said some
very profound things
so brothers and sisters too next time
inshallah uh come visit us if you have
any questions or answers for both
muslims christian jews hindu sikh
whatever you name it
from salaam and your brother ali assalam
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh